we are [ __ ] back to where we were
yeah all we gotta do is go upstairs we
got we got it we got to get past this
[ __ ]
I don't know [ __ ] hell any something
here
can they see me
hey just [ __ ] run it
[ __ ] around [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] do I get past them there's
no food or anything I don't understand
how to get past them
I'm gonna say so I get that mousy Mouse
anything in here that's good to fill
with trash huh how do I get that stinky
Mouse
was not using us to get the mouse know
that be so silly we have to take the
food from nice here mr. Goss jacket you
have to get the food from like this
person who's [ __ ] eating alright
you think I'll finish
they never gonna [ __ ] finish I gotta
get past them I got it the only place I
can goes mr. cosplay so he definitely
has some [ __ ] food or something
disgusting that sucking gross that's
just it's just gross okay
take on their top boarded up
strange combination lock care yes we've
been here we've been here but can't be
[ __ ] food in the guy's house any
[ __ ] food in here
and I catch a map and it's a slab
can I take that beer
I get to share this [ __ ] room so how
the [ __ ] do I get out of here
it's like I know I have to get past this
thing so [ __ ] do I gotta do
oh yeah
okay can I just like sneak by them holy
[ __ ]
okay what the [ __ ] you could just do
that okay
whoa what the [ __ ] okay okay
we just [ __ ] save I guess
yeah well anyway now let's just keep
going let's get going all right perfect
how can I use that printout I got paper
come on let's do this
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
we're in Chinese Book of Changes okay
well let me go through and just save
because that was really annoying I
didn't know you could [ __ ] just go
buy them some [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah they're on but I'm better I'll bet
around [ __ ] me in a [ __ ] mess over
there
good thing the janitors still around
that say can't go past there no yeah I'm
a third floor still think it's a little
confusing all right can I go past this
batch yes yes to save room right there
[Music]
might as well get one of these teriyaki
[ __ ] good and save of course I feel
blessed
okay now they're in [ __ ] over here so
we're going to the first floor then
going all the way across
we're going this match
you know that smell [ __ ]
sit down but really love snackies let's
go a little faster
okay sweat a lot faster
that [ __ ] was it it was six so thought
thought / / done okay
six to three dot dot slash slash perfect
it was last one three hamburger okay
yeah yeah brother
let's do this [ __ ] [ __ ] dark in here
okay board it up can't get in burn it up
can't get in
holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] is going on here Jesus Christ all
right
is there a guy are you that miss
anything
welcome to eat here now you can see the
difference in the shrine that's really
nice heart direction that's really good
I think that's still the calendar
crazy [ __ ] where's that going now I got
to count us off to the phones up do so
this litter here I'm gonna sconce dang
cancers office it's locked
oh [ __ ] is that
left [ __ ] sweetie what the [ __ ] knows
you best be leavin oh [ __ ]
long-legged holy [ __ ] I'm not gonna make
it it's the counselors two counts that
hey I'm at it hey can't follow my hair
well what the [ __ ] is this is there no
wall Buddha counseling record
oh no piece of counseling 17 Matt
mother's house way of negative trouble
[ __ ] [ __ ] improving encourage loser
activities such as reading signed by
there's yen officer okay
you know is this me
it's quite foggy outside
thanks man they said I should show my
ears but I find it difficult I have set
to graduation where should I get one
like my mom stop worrying so much
alright fares on be helpful at least
this weekend's going to be lit so clean
up the desk for me no privacy a
well-built closet what is that in the
trash can
I was throwing my stuff away with that
Tommy old photograph in the trash I was
a good thing it's a bicycle what she
does this okay so can I go there
fighting yet you know but sleepy and I
should go back to bed alright you said
it good event yeah I got no other choice
so I don't see why not
you know paper plane could wish my
dreams away from here where I could wake
up and find myself in a foreign land to
start a new life it's a stranger to all
oh how wonderful that back talking about
LA baby
there I go again nodding off I don't
know what the [ __ ] going on here I'll
be honest I really don't now I'm outside
now that's [ __ ] wet
hey [ __ ] down the road keep knocking the
poles yeah
how far off or it should turn a bear
plenty though that looks still a thing I
feel like in foreign movies there's
always like a should sound of paper
airplanes and [ __ ] but I'm sure like
with cell phones and [ __ ] they still do
that no no no
okay on the desk
[Music]
black-and-white impermanence
there's tuition officials during routine
inspection is fortunate felt like the
parish try to protect one of their Lord
of Death seeing the loyalty point there
was duty of messengers of death it was
then that people who died claimed see
their souls is okay
fascinating same
no [ __ ] lie that's that I guess let's
go in here
how about ice
- fingers crossed from the door do you
suppose regarded a little more like hot
betting will chime their hands look like
they should be holding something what
could they be missing well you saw the
[ __ ] organ [ __ ]
they had like something in their mouth
and then contestant or some [ __ ] out now
let's say let's say you know the other
side
George blocked Papaji workshop the [ __ ]
is this
I know in the car Lantern Spectre maybe
you can't upon Atlantic Spirit I've hurt
your gaze and stand unmoving make up
linear hold your breath don't panic keep
on movin on great how about dinner
so where's Lane inspector you got me
here
see in here o lanterns here maybe it's
all the puppets inside
shut the puppetry of the penis brick
furnace I remember she burns spirit
money to bless her health that's fair
money hey what is that a brick of
furnace
is all this [ __ ] puppeteers okay we
gotta keep movin though great this whole
Upstairs Downstairs [ __ ] again in the
basement
how's that spatch
you only figure out the wooden token on
its back can't really tell who's with
the hood on its head
see you lie right now put a cherry blood
is this for live jump blood on its hood
the [ __ ] is this
that was divine incense burner let's
three in sentence six tells the got
Sarnia birthplace and launches in
spiritual [ __ ]
my crying plants
many who they supposed to be that's that
spirit bunny I guess I gotta burn this
[ __ ] down
holy [ __ ] where they go
skipping this
just find a way I guess that
it's gonna fly in a way I guess not
either okay I'm gonna burn that incense
though the spirit money ain't a bad base
it's a brighter here than was here for
no same exact thing [ __ ] heads get
her spirit money
fire one out before an assembly gone
called what is that feathered fan
that's probably one things he got ahold
Oh what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is this
puppets got me in sad
I got a dark in here huh shut this [ __ ]
soon like options can fill with evil
over time okay
that's gather Dacula until they're gone
and until their one date a client they
twist the mantra storm okay
what the [ __ ]
you're gonna get me yeah
okay
that was a little cray-cray
I need a [ __ ] save soon see what's
upstairs
what's that lantern did clock right
Richard one of the seams blocked
it's the same bill here so this was
sweet just a nice way to get across
that's where they do projection room oh
[ __ ] is Lankan guy various films in the
rack tangled together the film of the
media is being projected from here
there's a million things to say or any
of the films we could play yeah
[Music]
don't do anything okay
[ __ ] so what's actually playing right
now then
I need this theory incense soap anything
buried take them and let's get the [ __ ]
out of here oh here we go
should I watch this
[ __ ] is going on over there okay so I
got the incense to burn though I got it
all the way back down to the bottom
floor
holy [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] he got me hey got me
what every time you die you gotta go
through this thing
what's wrong
Oh unless you know more about the thing
that killed you okay
a sec okay
you saved then
let me
find the incense machine thing actually
a bit it's in here now who's the [ __ ]
top runners deep puppy ders
was that I thought they said like
okay so I'm not supposed to move at all
okay well now right now there's the
incense machine okay
all right go mom does incense ignore any
kinds of prayers you prefer a stick it's
only for a week to live as myself okay
thank you
suppose if I can leave this bishop
pretty good
now again
okay so maybe those are the one doing it
I like uh maybe that's [ __ ] it
now that care that me safe
saving just saving saving look here in
there
save me yeah okay well yeah brother
you know yeah brother let's do this
[ __ ]
Childress in words okay so I'm just
getting warm for you I don't know what
that means here you know the president
what's in this gym
it's [ __ ] disgusting in here so funny
though
hello
any fo never I guess nothing important
on the bookshelves what about in here
cat looks familiar is a key inside mmm
hell yeah brother
oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] far s away [ __ ]
it's like 10 years away uh forget about
that yeah we have to go all the way back
to the roof
there we go
well [ __ ] [ __ ] me to pass them that
scares [ __ ] [ __ ] long-ass quarter
their dad it's not computer herself
the [ __ ] side
sir there's a birdcage puppet lies
locked inside its kind of hold on never
seen a star before I don't think I could
take the roof cage but it's alright kid
down
okay
let's see here
at least this is game if you perish like
eqr stuff which is kind of cool okay
that's like the broadcasting room
there are more films to play broadcast
equipment take a sound
let's say we used to switch tracks you'd
see me say four tracks on it
I'd hate track player you track yeah
okay get the [ __ ] out of here
okay so I need a check player to get the
puppet out and to go through still let's
see here
mm-hmm you like a smile baby this is
more where that came from
all right long
this [ __ ] how [ __ ] team I going I
could go this way
well I don't even know where the [ __ ] I
am now the scene is trying to remind me
something now probably not your American
hands puppet play this [ __ ]
so they need that puppet on the cage
there's something here a track right
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's a dead end yeah sure
I leave it know what to do first
let me just backtrack just a tiny bit to
put the hey track in because I really
don't know what's [ __ ] next okay the a
check is this way I'm sure I had to go
through the lanes in person again
I guess I did
isn't the [ __ ] lamp the light over
here
come on Atlanta guy
you know like [ __ ] Ron [ __ ]
broadcasting room yeah
okay
okay
laughs you guys should be over here
right
yeah
[Music]
okay let's do it closely
the [ __ ] was it
didn't date that day okay okay
[Music]
okay all right looks like we're gonna
have to do this the hard way boys and
that is to just straight-up look at what
the keys are detention piano keys
now this isn't like cheating we know
it's easy to listen to music and play it
this is gonna take Kenny out ten hours I
do so so we're just gonna look it up
okay
tension piano kids being outside being a
sign
piano piano puzzle okay okay I don't sit
here two three two seven seven six two
three - okay let's do this right here
two three two seven seven six five break
down okay
all right I think we can accomplish this
now I think we can accomplish this now
back up let's back up
two three four five six seven hell yeah
brother
we got the puppet holy [ __ ] that was
scary gave it to me his doors open
inside the puppet take it out [ __ ] okay
so I got to put it on one of the hands I
guess I can put it on the hands that's
not a problem okay not the first time I
put a puppet on a hand is that [ __ ]
lantern guy over here how does the music
stop to chase if I can take ten years I
say gotta go upstairs to the roof there
you go here let me go left
Varick yeah okay
okay we got that one little fat dead
so let me go right this time I guess
right I haven't gotten here I really
hope it goes back to the school would be
so nice doors been unlocked hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah okay I gotta get the roof this
is good this is really good level design
thank goodness but take it like ten
years
how the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] way [ __ ] I
thought you died
okay let's say sound okay so now we can
go play the other thing yeah maybe we'll
get a different air okay so not too bad
I think actually that the room is like
over here
it was like really high up [ __ ] yeah
this is dope
it's gonna be really [ __ ] up down
there we got muchachos you better hold
on to your box cause it's about to be
[ __ ] up in here it's about three
[ __ ] up in here
there we go zero to five one two what
zero to five okay over at this down zero
to five one two one two one two okay
three to five one two one
okay that's ready up here snitcher this
way their Informer
poor Tom Aldi now why
snitcher
I don't know why thought this is about
what didn't we check out yet
was there a lock early on I couldn't
remember combination yeah this [ __ ]
his tongue is so long that smell bike
only we're the best pillow curfew no I
don't wear that cold [ __ ] okay I wear
the target [ __ ] okay
okay well they don't into the roof
anymore
you don't need to go to the puppeteer
see another hand thing yeah
no the other right camera what the [ __ ]
was over here you save
that goes outside again
don't you if I want to go outside
I mean the by fence dip not at the
basement was your something in the
basement that was lost I can't [ __ ]
remember it's been so long
let's see here
seen lot
okay we did the incense
why don't you burn that thing
touken so this shouldn't be an anything
left unless you're something at the very
end camera
something [ __ ] locked over here
who's in here again locked [ __ ]
well we're getting close seems like the
last part of this whole thing
yes we
so you're going back to that pub thing
let's go back in here and then let's go
all the way back over here I think this
suggests TM focuses
I don't have I have any clues
I have a code I just have no idea what
the [ __ ] do with it now
this is a projector to hand again
[Music]
the [ __ ] middle door inside might be
another way around
[ __ ] all this say might be another way
around its just locked
oh okay the number
zero to five one two what
wait if I can forget that one
zero
to
five one two one here we go
how is it
your country appreciates your assistance
okay
what's left is only Dalton the [ __ ]
that was his badge
even if it throws up and they go through
silly
okay did he leave anything funny
okay well you basically got them all
faster you go this way then
my name's all the [ __ ] hi boss
well they were down here more there we
go
yeah I thought I discussed it okay we're
at the [ __ ] go I gotta go all the way
down here come on O'Lantern people
you're easy to stick forever huh yes
okay waiting all day
Anna you know happy now how's that one
bag out today no more down where I got
today yeah good good
okay walk take your leggings this way
okay
and we got the copper oh yeah brother
okay basement okay get the [ __ ] out of
here
mmm-hmm yeah that's pretty clear-cut now
all right I think right goes back to the
building and then down goes to the
basement and then all the way to the
right is where I want to go okay I've
been trying to go this way for a long
time honey
a long time okay
I don't mean to do that
all right once we go through or welp I
save and then we'll call another episode
babies hmm we're gonna find a safe
station if you know what I made [ __ ]
that's my shoes no wait no yeah we're
hanging out here
all the way here to my classroom so kind
of classroom now is individual a bother
over there so a teacher sure nobody else
meets at the meetings right of course
miss this book list is quite system it's
here uh please be careful with it okay
every this book could be trouble but
should be afraid of pursue knowledge
right yeah with you know that Birla in
fact I think we're seeing also said
something like that before you're just
like it the core just thinking we see
incidents was daughter
night wigs
see miss Missy and mr. shank chat a lot
relationship mm-hmm very curious very
curious as well in your bank with my way
book club reading list okay it's just
like the end of the game
I said slow one of these mirrors is
gonna show something different yeah I
see you know Miss yet what are you doing
out my hair CJ I've always show concern
for students were a little rebellious
remember what you did huh [ __ ] you
talking about you forgot me you know
what I remember
yeah there's a harmless piece of paper
right and said I had to die here to die
many other students had to die
was it you you just causing me trouble
you're driving me crazy sometimes when
you trip up you never able to get back
again do you rent everything if you had
a problem I couldn't even come to me
instead she dumped me for god knows what
happened so basically you ratted them
out she read them up and there's
consequences over there oh shut if you
weren't here all will be well good thing
you got shoes on and you here am I just
walking into [ __ ] nothing the [ __ ] is
this hon did they
is this Buckland ah the Buddha is it the
but I'm not really sure
might be scholars helping justice Chang
hey it was tidy no no no my aunt's
togethers have a bear here are my
questions hi guys
ask about prospects it look like by my
choice doesn't follow my heart
yeah laughing answer
family heard you qualify have a second
chance yeah yeah
because I was related level dreamer yes
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on here
[Music]
youth is hardly ever given a choice
pushed her the grind until their
innocence fades away I become a wedded
horse on the carousel of life a jumbled
mess of lifeless emotion infused with
frantic energy
I spent ever faster hairspray get that
app
to enter its on computers now
I'll radio seems like the static and
we're almost coming from this maybe we
can get something a tenant with a bed
all right same station y'all we'll see
you on the next episode it looks like
this is a chapter two is done thank you
very much
oh my god one y'all see ya